What about when the client says for us it's all about conversion and to win the and then they through that
Let's see what happens with the free leads you sent us. That's a great question
I've covered this and I'm gonna cover this again. So one I've had this happen. I had this happen recently
In fact, I'll tag you in a video one. There's a video that I'm gonna share with you. So client says
They say hey, let's see what happens these leads. Okay, I did a
Specific lie for this thing was on a Friday two Fridays ago. So here's what I say is I say hey look mr. Business owner
If I sent you let's so let's say you've sent in three leads
I say hey if those three leads that I sent you if you close all three of those
Is it safe to assume you're gonna close a hundred percent of them?
Well, no, of course not. Okay. Well if you close zero of those three leads
Is it safe to assume that you're gonna close zero leads? Well, no
Okay, so the reason I'm bringing that up because
We can't base this off of three leads unless you're a hundred percent closer basing us off of three leads is the most
Short-sighted move we could ever make in the world
because and I say that say I work I've worked with some people in the past where I sent them ten leads they've closed zero and
Then the next ten leads they closed seven out of ten and they average almost 40% close rate
So I'm not sending you like that. I hope you didn't misunderstand me. Mr. Business owner
I'm not sending you guys this just so you could like and so I'm not gonna keep sending you leads for you to close the
Deal I'm sending you these leads so you can see the quality of the lead knowing that it is a numbers game
Okay, so I just don't want you to get confused. I'm sending you a couple whether you close them or not
That's on you. You don't have to pay me. Those are free. That's on you
But we need to talk in three days something like that because guys it's ridiculous
Like think about that think about like and I'm glad you brought this up dude
Like the people like what kind of balls these people have hey, thanks for the free
Like think about this. Hey guys
Hey one appreciate the free leads
Let me see if I make any money from those free leads to add further value to what you've already given me for free and
Then and only then will we talk then and only then will we do business on screw that person
Okay, so to me what that that might be like if you're getting that a lot and some people just have that in their mind
If you're getting that a lot, that's probably something that you're you're doing in the call
That first call where you need to kind of you need to do that pullback
You need to do what we talked about today with like this is a perfect example from today
Hey, like in your own way, you need to let them know that this this is not this isn't contingent upon them closing leads period
I'm sending you the leads so you can test them out
But this is a numbers game and I send you 20 leads
Okay, how many how many you how many free leads you want? Right? You're in business. I don't run a non-profit neither do you?
I'm gonna send you a couple
I'm happy to send you a couple more but we can't wait like if that's the game you're playing this isn't gonna work like
Be bold know your worth like that person right there if they say oh, well then this doesn't work. Cool
Walk away from that deal. This is a that's a perfect example of what we talked about today
Is this the kind of shit people pull I had that's it was Ricardo Ricardo's the one that did that shit to me
He's like hey, man. Yeah
We'll see what comes to these leads and then and then we'll talk no, no, no
That's not how so this does not work like that Ricardo wrong guy wrong place wrong time
And I said that exact thing I just said and I said no we're gonna talk
I'm gonna send you one more thing. We're gonna talk and then he goes to me cool
Go smell you want Ricardo, but I'm not doing business with you